how well do you know the voices in
Avatar The Last Airbender and The Legend
of Korra hey you have finally connected
with your spiritual self some characters
underwent casting changes from one
season to another while uncle Iroh had
to be replaced during the original
series if you thought some of these
voices sounded familiar you just might
have been right what I'm recording any
of the dialogue
I'll make kind of an over exaggerated
face because to get the whole thing
working let's start out by taking a look
at the legendary avatar Korra herself
well rather let's take a listen you're
the only ones who are gonna need a
hospital and for your sake I hope
there's one nearby Korra is voiced by
Janet Varney who you might recognize
from her part on the TV show you're the
worst where she plays Becka Barbara what
you she was also every Barret on stand
against evil and Janet on fortune rookie
if you want to hear more of Janet check
out her podcast the JV club which she
launched all the way back in 2012 she
said that it was a privilege to portray
Korra and she loved being able to lend a
voice to her incredible journey
[Applause]
depending on how much of a 90s sitcom
fan you are you might be able to
recognize the voice of Mako from The
Legend of Korra everything will be
alright we just need to get out of here
that's none other than David Faustino
whose other most well known work as the
classic show married with children where
he played one of the titular children
bud Bundy according to the book we're
not allowed to take any kind of
compensation even if it's these not only
is David one of the legend of korra
voice actors but he's a big fan of the
show however it might surprise you to
know that his favorite character is not
Mako it's Bolin
he's also provided the voice for dagger
the deranged on DreamWorks dragons and
Helia on Winx Club I realized I love you
Korra
now we get to david Faustino's favorite
character Mako's fun-loving younger
brother bolin so what do you think Korra
Bolin Scott some ooze huh
this part on The Legend of Korra was PJ
Byrnes very first voice acting role but
not his last he went on to play
firestorm in Justice League action in
addition to his many live-action roles
PJ appeared in the movie the wolf of
Wall Street and portrayed the principal
on the show big little lies according to
PJ he wasn't a fan of Avatar The Last
Airbender before joining the Legend of
Korra cast but that quickly changed so
you see we're together well not together
together more like friends Tenzin has
the distinction of being the oldest
living airbending master and the child
of Avatar Aang and Katara he helped
guide Korra on her journey to master
bending the elements and you might be
able to recognize his voice
okay maybe you'd be able to place them
better if you can see him pounding his
fists on a desk and demanding pictures
of spider-man yes Tenzin is voiced by JK
Simmons who's best known for portraying
Daily Bugle editor-in-chief Jay jonah
Jameson in the world of Marvel you might
also have seen him as Clyde Pickett in
Veronica Mars or counterpart as Howard
silk some of his other animated credits
include gene from American Dad and Lenny
turtle table from Bojack horseman it's
lovely to meet you Mac who told me so
much about you do you recognize the star
behind Asami Sato
her name is seychelle gabriel and she
started out auditioning for a very
different role she tried out for the
part of Katara on Avatar The Last
Airbender but ended up voicing princess
Yue way on the show instead and when it
came time to join the cast of Legend of
Korra she also didn't get her first
choice since she was hoping to play
Korra herself outside of the avatar
universe
say Chell played Lara on Sleepy Hollow
and Lords on falling skies I know it
sounds
say this but I'm really glad I hit you
with my moped saying that Lin beifong
didn't start out as Cora's biggest fan
is a little bit of an understatement
just because the city's throwing you
this big to-do don't think you're
something special
Lin is voiced by Mindy sterling whom you
might recognize from the Austin Powers
films where she played Frau she's also
elder Annabelle in a series of
unfortunate events and Pam on blackish
okay you can show yourselves let's talk
about the person behind tenzin amp
Emma's oldest daughter Jinora
being caught I can project my spirit
into it we have to say chilling
Adventures of sabrina Stark here Dan
Shipka does have a pretty distinctive
voice maybe she just likes portraying
characters with incredible powers and
it's hard to blame her since both Jinora
and Sabrina are both pretty amazing but
before she gained her powers most of us
knew her as Sally Draper on the hit show
Mad Men a role that she earned when she
was just seven years old
you might also recognize her as the
voice of onna on Sophia the first or
Kimmy the little sister on unbreakable
kimmy schmitt long before there was
Korra
there was Avatar Aang who fought to
unite the nations although he did find
some time for fun along the way well you
go with me in Avatar The Last Airbender
Aang was voiced by Zach Tyler Aizen who
recorded most of his characters dialogue
from his home in Connecticut via
satellite although the last airbender is
his most well known work he's also lent
his voice to many other animated
characters he was Pablo in the backyard
against Andrew Mulligan on little bill
and appeared in an episode of Dora the
Explorer as little red fish
The Legend of Korra took place 70 years
after the events of Avatar The Last
Airbender and during that time
Aang grew up had a family and eventually
passed on so when an older angry
appeared he needed a new voice hello my
son
adult eng is portrayed by DB sweeney
who played Larry on the sitcom Two and a
Half Men and was Doug Dorsey in the film
of the cutting edge it's not magic it's
waterbending in the original series
Katara was voiced by Mae Whitman who was
also the star behind the Painted Lady
and Lou 10 if you don't recognize her
voice have you ever smelled your dirty
socks let me tell you Mae's been in
shows like Arrested Development and good
girls as well as movies like The Perks
of Being a Wallflower and Scott Pilgrim
vs. the world yeah we're totally getting
a Katara vibe me captured a young Katara
but for The Legend of Korra the
character was replaced by a different
actor I could help guide your healing
process but whether you get better or
not is up to you older Katara was played
by Eva Marie Saint who's appeared in
many classic films such as Alfred
Hitchcock's North by Northwest and Elia
Kazan's on the waterfront right and this
is Katara my flying sister Katara is an
incredible waterbender but dealing with
her brother Sokka definitely helped to
teach her the art of patience yeah yeah
an ancient art unique to our culture
blah blah blah not only did Jack de
santé provide the voice for Sokka but
he's the reason for sokka's lively
personality according to Avatar The Last
Airbender co-creator Bryan Konietzko the
character was much more low-key until
Jack showed up full of ideas and
improvisational skills Jack also showed
off his sense of humor on all that and
appeared in shows like the dragon Prince
100 things to do before school lamb
battleground and adult Sacco only
appears in a flashback during the Legend
of Korra and for this appearance he was
voiced by Chris Hardwick I once bested a
man with my trusty boomerang who was
able to firebend with his mind while you
won't hear much of his voice in the
series you can't hear a lot more of it
on shows like the talking dead and the
wall you're the Airbender you're just a
child
well you're just a teenager we all know
Zuko had one of the best character arcs
in The Last Airbender so let's take a
look at the face behind the voice three
years ago today I was banished I lost it
all I want it back Dante Bosco is the
voice of Zuko and an admitted Zatara
shipper he and Katara voice actress Mae
Whitman both worked on american dragon
jake long as love interest jaqen rose
respectively you might also know Dante
from camp camp hook or the narrator for
Star Wars Galaxies of adventure when we
saw a young Zuko in the episode Zuko
alone he was voiced by Elijah Runcorn
who appeared in Crazy Love as Bobby like
many of the original Last Airbender
characters Zuko was voiced by someone
else in the sequel series we still don't
know how many Red Lotus members might be
out there hiding that's the iconic voice
of Bruce Davidson who played senator
Kelly in the x-men movies and Stuart on
the Fosters with that stance what sweet
uncle Iroh was portrayed by legendary
voice actor Mako yo Matsu he voiced many
characters over the years including aku
from Samurai Jack and splinter in the
TMNT movie sadly he passed away during
book 2 and was replaced by Greg Baldwin
who also took over as aku ever since I
was put in here you have been very kind
to me
although Greg does an admirable
impression of Makos voice he refuses to
sing leaves from the vine because Makos
rendition is just too perfect to touch I
poured your tea because I wanted to Toph
beifong may be one-of-a-kind but she's
had three different voice actors so
what's your strategy for taking him down
it's gonna get your glow on and hit him
with a little avatar state action
there's Mikayla Jill Murphy also known
as Jessie flower who played young Franny
in Meet the Robinsons ChaCha in the
emperor's new school and suyin beifong
in the Legend of Korra despite the years
passing after The Last Airbender
some nicknames are just hard to shake
fine follow me twinkle toes that's the
voice of Kate Higgins who was Aurora in
Ralph's breaks the internet and Sakura
umberto Naruto next generation last but
not least there's this Toph nice to see
you again twinkle toes she's voiced by
Felice sampler who voiced a Mimi
indigenous venture and key in sword gaya
the animation you mean you haven't
guessed you don't see the family
resemblance
although Azula is the Stars favorite
character to voice she's far from her
only one I will not hesitate to bring
you down Gradle Isle
also known as Greg Griffon also
portrayed other Last Airbender
characters including Michi Tommen and
kya
just to name a few in the Legend of
Korra
she played Ming hua as well as some
other minor roles I would sign of the
franchise she's known as Daphne Blake
and scooby-doo and guess who and Selena
Kyle in the video game Batman Arkham
City so let's take a moment to
appreciate our animal friends like Appa
Momo Naga and more all of the animals in
both series are voiced by Dee Bradley
Baker who provides a wide variety of
sound effects for our favorite creatures
he also plays an animal on the show
American Dad although closed the fish
does talk America's favorite German fish
you also might recognize him as perry
the platypus on Phineas and Ferb which
voice actors performance is your
favorite would you change up any of the
casting choices if you could share your
thoughts and opinions with us and your
fellow fans in the comments section
below and don't forget to click on the
subscribe button for more new videos
from us here at the things thanks for
watching